[Music]
just who in the hell do you think you
are
[Applause]
[Music]
don't shoot
what's that he says welcome to the
frickin guardians of the galaxy only he
didn't use frickin
look out I tried guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you
hey youtubers happy Superbowl new
guardians let's break it down the
awesome thing here is I think that we
are looking at eco the Living Planet in
the background of this shot so just
because so much awesome stuff is
happening there's a new round of the
Marvel giveaway there's a new spider-man
action figure that's crazy articulated
so that's what the giveaway is for all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
so for the most part we get to meet all
the other big characters of the movie we
get to meet Alicia who's actually name
is kismet in the comics so I'm just
gonna go through this shot by a shot you
see the Guardians standing in the
audience chamber of kismet she's the
leader of this genetically engineered
perfect people in the comics she was
created by the Enclave she has the
ability to manipulate cosmic energy
she's functionally immortal so she's
basically this perfect being so I don't
know how literally they did that for the
movie she might not have the ability to
wield cosmic powers but the way James
Gunn talked about her she sounds like
she's the leader of this super uptight
peoples that hire the Guardians to get
rid of this monster in things go
sideways originally the idea is that she
was created by the Enclave this you know
beehive of scientists to be a clone of
Adam warlock she's like a female version
of Adam warlock which is why she looks
like this so if they never do Adam
warlock in the movies you can think that
at least they did a gold version of a
character that's very similar to Adam
warlock so just look out for Easter eggs
for him whenever they have scenes with
her the way they cut the trailer they
jump around a lot you see Drax jump down
in the middle of that sentence of hers
like who the hell do you think you are
well we're the Guardians so this planet
that he's on that you see throughout the
trailer looks like ego the Living Planet
this is a big wide shot of that so it
looks exactly like him in the comics but
we know he's star-lords father and he
made himself a human body that is played
by Kurt Russell so they haven't fully
explained how that's gonna work he
doesn't appear in the trailer but I do
think that we're seeing ego the Living
Planet in his planet form you see yondu
here co-piloting the Milano with
star-lord then later in the trailer baby
Groot and Rocket formally invite him to
the guardians he said welcome to the
guardians only he didn't say fricken
if you're not a big Fleetwood Mac fan
the song that's playing in the
background is called the chain the cool
thing about this is that this was my
fraternity's song in college so this has
some special significance for me but the
song itself is all about the idea of
family keep the chain together keep the
family together and in this context or
just talking about this new Guardians
team in the family has grown you finally
see nebula wearing a Ravagers Guardians
looking uniform so we don't know how
long she's gonna be with them but she's
just going crazy Karen Gillan's gonna be
amazing I love this montage of Gamora to
her holding one of Rockettes mega giant
guns he just has like the biggest guns
ever and as part of the comedy of his
character is that the smallest creature
has the biggest weapons the cool thing
about that if you're really happy about
rocket and Groot in the film is that
James Gunn has talked about the third
film actually not being a direct sequel
in being more of a Groot rocket spin-off
film they added the CG of yondu's Finn
it looks way cooler in this movie and
they obviously did the comic book Finn
the big one the way James Gunn explained
it is that he just had a different
version in the first movie and in this
movie when the Ravagers revolt against
him he has to have baby Groot help him
get the Finn so that he can control the
arrow and help break them out so I like
the way that we saw this without the
extra CG in earlier trailers with
everybody just flying around in zero-g
and now we know what's going on it's
like a bigger version of that scene from
the first movie over yonder just takes
all those dudes down with the arrow
[Music]
a little more mantas geeking out on baby
Groot ah he's so cute I love the moment
with her later in the trailer where she
just gets taken out by that debris and
Drax is like sorry sorry I tried guys
they haven't said too much about what
role she's going to play going forward
but she's going to be an infinity war
she was one of the people that was
confirmed I've already done a video for
that so I'll add a link at the end of
this so she's going to be a really big
character even though we haven't seen
that much of her this is probably my new
favorite shot of nebula and just look at
the colors in the background too you
just have to appreciate the way James
Gunn makes a frame one of the best
things about guardians was its color
palette just the way he painted those
images even though I'm sure the story is
gonna be really amazing for this movie
the characters will be great it's going
to look amazing
this right here is taser face he's sort
of like the new leader of the Ravagers
after they revolt against yondu he's a
character from way back in the comics
he's a deep cut James Gunn explain the
joke from before the first movie came
out that led to him being part of this
film so originally he wasn't anywhere in
these movies but James Gunn always likes
to make jokes people are like who's
gonna be in the first guardians movie so
this is a couple years ago he was just
joking around he threw a fake spoiler
out there that said taser face come to
now he's actually put him in this movie
so he's just a big badass from the
classic guardians comics the one where
yondu was on the team hero shot see they
keep going back to this planet I keep
thinking that this is ego the Living
Planet just based on the look of all
this organic material behind them but
let me know what you guys think of the
trailer so far I'm not expecting to see
Kurt Russell himself maybe til the last
trailer they kind of did that with
vision during the Avengers age of Ultron
trailer they did that with spider-man
during the last Captain America civil
war trailer so what'll probably happen
next is that they'll release a longer
version of this that will explain a
little bit more about the story beads
with some more finished CGI so you look
at the earlier trailers and there's some
repeated footage but like the yondu
stuff just has a bunch of extra stuff
that they've added since
they've started finishing all that stuff
they're gonna be editing the movie til
right up until they release it so
there's still footage that isn't
finished yet but they have plenty for a
bunch of trailers a lot of you are
asking about Thanos infinity gems I
don't think that James gonna said
anything about the infinity gems but he
did say that there was no Thanos in the
film and he's not lying he's not
misleading people
so if Thanos shows up it will be in thor
ragnarok not in this movie so we can
start speculating about what this
post-credit scene is gonna be because
thor ragnarok is the next movie after
this not including spider-man but it's
more likely that this movie would have
connected tissue with Thor just because
they're both in outer space
so let me know in the comments if you
have any requests for special bonus
videos on characters I'll probably do an
ego the Living Planet video tomorrow I
want to do a group video too but as for
spider-man or other trailers I'm not
expecting any other Marvel footage this
weekend but like they drop that Justice
League teaser picture there might be
some more stuff like that from the other
studios so I'll be posting more Super
Bowl trailers as the weekend gets on
there's going to be some stranger things
season two so just look out for that
later tonight while you wait for that
you can click here to learn about the
guardians that are confirmed for
infinity war and you can click here for
more Super Bowl trailers thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you in the next video